our phone number when you want to call
in is six one seven eight three zero
forty seven fifty I think we've got time
really for probably just one more call
and that call is gonna be from the five
one six area code caller from five one
six tell us your name and what your
question is
Oh first note nobody there five one six
is not there I'll try one more we're
gonna have to make time for another call
I guess I know yeah we're gonna we're
gonna end up running out of time let's
try let's try four four three we're
gonna try from the four four three area
code who would be our last call or four
four three who's this
Donovan Peterson what's going on Donovan
not much it's really great to be on the
show and I just had a question about
whether you could give us a brief
explanation about Michael Flynn's
involvement with Russia and how
significant that involvement is when it
comes to his proximity to Trump well I
mean we've been talking about this
really for months and we just had the
the indictment very recently so
generally speaking at this point what we
are being told by the defenders of Trump
in Lou in light of the Flynn indictment
is that Flynn was acting completely on
his own nobody knew what he was doing
nobody directed him to do anything
etc it increasingly is a storyline
that's falling apart we now have emails
from katie mcfarland who was a trump
transition adviser emailing numerous
other people about the meetings that
Michael Flynn had planned or already had
had with Russians including the Russian
ambassador Sergei his lyac we know that
Reince Priebus and Sean Spicer and many
others were on those email chains we
know about Donald Trump Jr's involvement
he had to answer questions behind closed
doors in front of a Senate committee
this week so I don't think we know the
full scope of it yet but the absolutist
line that Flynn was acting in a complete
vacuum almost reminiscent of Seinfeld's
Bubble Boy completely isolated from
everything that that at least we know
not to be true although we can't yet say
how far it goes oh thank you for that
explanation all right no problem Donovan
thank you very very good to hear from
you and that is gonna do it for calls
this week we will take a break and be
back after this